SPEAKER 1: Benjamin is
now the favored son.
You other brothers
go, because there
could be some harm on the way.
But don't let me
lose my beloved son.
So I'm going to
begin in chapter 42,
after Joseph has read
all of pharaoh's dreams,
after he's become a
high-ranking official.
And now the brothers are
about to come to him.
This kind of book end
narrative for the Joseph story.
Chapter 42, "And Jacob saw that
there were provisions in Egypt,
and Jacob said to his sons,
'Why are you fearful?'
And he said, 'Look, I
have heard that there
are provisions in Egypt.
Go down there, get us provisions
from there that we may live
and not die.'
And the 10 brothers of Joseph
went to buy grain from Egypt.
But Benjamin, Joseph's
brother, Jacob
did not send with
his brothers, for he
thought, lest harm befall him."
Benjamin is now the favored son.
He is the new Joseph
to his brothers.
You other brothers
go, because there
could be some harm on the way.
But don't let me lose my
beloved son, the son of Rachel.
"And the sons of Israel
came to buy provisions
among those who
came, for there was
famine in the land of Canaan.
As for Joseph, he was
regent of the land,
he was provider
to all the people.
And Joseph's brothers came
and bowed down to him,
and their faces to the ground.
And Joseph saw his brothers
and recognized them,
and he played the stranger to
them and spoke harshly to them.
And he says, 'Where
have you come from?'"
And just notice here
what's going on.
Notice they bow
down to the ground.
And if you remember your
details in the text,
you know this is specifically
from Joseph's dreams,
when all of the [INAUDIBLE]
bowed down to Joseph.
And now you're going to see
this same image of the bowing
down repeated again
and again and again.
"And Joseph recognized
his brothers
but they did not recognize him.
And Joseph remembered the dreams
he had dreamed about them.
And he said to them,
'You are spies!
To see the land's nakedness
you have come,' And they said
to him, 'No, my lord, for your
servants have come to buy food.
We are all the sons of one man.
We are honest.
Your servants would never be
spies.'" And he said to them,
'No, for the land's nakedness
you have come to see.'
And it's this weird accusation
he makes against them.
You are spies.
But I want you to think
about what does this
have to do to the previous
episode that we've seen?
This second part
of the Joseph story
is a playing out
of the first part.
He needs them to
see their misdeeds.
He needs them to replay
that drama one more
time to get them to stop and
to turn back from their ways,
to see their errors.
So why is he accusing
them of spies?
I think it's simple enough.
Is that not what
they accuse Joseph
of being when his father
would send them out
to bring ill report?
What is he accusing them of now?
He's accusing them
of being spies.
It's a replay of
that first story.
"12 brothers your servants are,
and we are the sons of one man
in the land of
Canaan, and, look,
the youngest is now with our
father, and one is no more.'
And Joseph said to them,
"That's just what I told.
You are spies.
You shall not leave this place
unless your youngest brother
comes here.
Send one of you to
bring your brother.
And as for the rest of
you, you will be detained,
and your words will be tested
as to whether the truth is
with you.
And if not, by Pharaoh,
you must be spies.'
And he put them under
guard for three days.
And Joseph said to
them on the third day,
'Do this and live,
for I fear God.
If you are honest, let
one of your brothers
be detained in this
very guard-house,
and the rest of you go
forth and bring back
provisions to stave off
the famine in your homes.
And your youngest brother
you shall bring to me,
that your words may be
confirmed and you need not die.'
And they said each to
his brother, 'Alas,
we are guilty for our brother
whose mortal distress we
saw when he pleaded with
us and we did not listen.
That is why this
distresses overtaken us.'"
You can see what's
going on here.
The plan is working.
The brothers are
recognizing already
the way in which that which
they had done to Joseph
is coming to bear here.
"Then Reuben spoke out
to them in these words,
'Didn't I say to you, do
not sin against the boy?
And you would not listen.
And now, look, his
blood is requited.'"
Look it, it's the
same pattern here.
Remember, the first
story, they all
speak together with one voice.
Then the first voice that
singles himself out is Reuben.
It's the same pattern
repeated here.
They all speak with one voice.
Then Ruben speaks
out one more time.
And he even brings out,
"Look, his blood is requited."
And, of course, Joseph
recognizes all of this
and he weeps.
And Joseph gives orders that
they fill their bag with grain
and fill it with silver.
And, of course, when the
brothers discover this,
they're horrified.
Now they'll be accused
of being spies,
be accused of being thieves.
What Joseph is kind of
reminding them of here
as what he was sold to in
Egypt for-- for that money.
He's putting the money
right back into their bags
as this constant reminder.
And, of course, they report
to their father everything
that has transpired in Egypt.
How now Simeon is the
one who's left there.
And in order to get
Simeon back, there, again,
has to be this exchange.
There has to be a sacrifice.
We must bring back Benjamin
in order to bring back Simeon.
And Israel's response
is startling.
"Jacob their father said to
them, 'Me you have bereaved.
Joseph is no more and
Simeon is no more,
and Benjamin you would take!
It is I who bear all.'
And Reuben spoke to
his father, saying,
'My two sons you may
put to death if I do not
bring him back to you.
Place him in my hands and
I will return him to you.'"
And here, again,
what do you see?
Reuben working so hard to get
back into his father's graces,
to really offer up
something absurd.
Yes, of course, this will
make Israel feel better.
If you don't bring
him back, he's
going to kill his two grandsons.
Reuben's so
desperate to get back
in his father's
good graces, what
he's willing to say is, I'll
sacrifice my two sons on behalf
of Benjamin.
And, of course, this isn't going
to get anywhere with Israel.
And he said, "My son shall
not go down with you,
for his brother is dead."
And look at this line.
"And he alone remains."
And think about all of
the brothers hearing this.
Benjamin alone remains.
I will not send him with
you, which essentially means,
I'll keep him, and
Simeon's just going
to have to stay there in Egypt.
Imagine what this is, what these
brothers are witnessing here,
all on behalf of Benjamin.
"And should harm befall him
on the way you are going,
you would bring down my gray
head in sorrow to shale."
It's the same repetition.
He won't be consoled.
You will bring my head down
to shale in this sorrow.
It's a complete replay
of the Joseph story.
And, of course, what we need
to anticipate now-- because,
of course, we know they
will be going back to Egypt.
And they will be bringing
Benjamin with them.
SPEAKER 2: Thank
you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our Highlight series
and invite you to explore
all of Hillsdale College's
online courses.
They are free and for
everyone who loves to learn.